they have systematically found a way to
bring back the players
that they wanted to bring back now with
chris godwin
i'm surprised still surprised they
franchise tagged him i thought they'd
let him go because they have enough good
receivers they can bump up
the depth chart bring back antonio brown
scotty miller tyler johnson whoever they
would draft this year in a draft that
once again is loaded with
receivers the 17 million per year for
shaq barrett which he
admitted was the best offer that he got
in free agency there was no one else out
there and now i think they got lucky
because in this year you're not gonna
have somebody who's just gonna say let's
go get the best player on the buccaneers
defense just to disrupt them
and say hey we have shaq barrett right
people were making football decisions up
business decisions but
between those two levante david rob
gronkowski
ryan suck up an important guy to keep
around given the roberto aguayo
misadventures we're down to two
we had we've had eight on this graphic
for weeks we're down to antonio brown
amazing
and leonard fernett and what do you
think
they're going to do there's reporting
from espn that
that they want to keep both guys which i
would expect them to say
i don't expect them to come out in the
aftermath of the super bowl where both
of these guys had
contributions that they made throughout
the course of the season and say oh
we're done with those guys
but they've got to want whatever the
buccaneers are willing to pay
do you think that they find a way to
keep frenette
and a b around well i
i don't think it's a top priority i
don't i think it's one of those where
they're going to look at it like
you know it's icing on the cake you know
first off fournette he's he's
probably gonna hold out a little bit
here just to try to find the best
possible deal he could get and squeeze
every dollar
out of his career this might be one of
the last times he gets a chance to kind
of hit free agency and
and get a you know a big big number
attached to his name as far as salary
now they're not they're not desperate at
the running back position we know we saw
during the year ronald jones was their
guy
he's got talent you know he's got a
little bit of everything you know power
size speed can do it all and you know
the other factor too is
where they are sitting in the draft at
32 you know
that that's prime oh we might get the
top running back in the draft territory
too
so that could play into this you know
this
this position and how they value it and
everything else there too
i'm sure they'd like to have them back
but i don't think it's a guy they're
going to overpay
like one dollar to and then antonio
brown
i mean again you kind of said it already
with the the
chris godwin thing i mean they don't
really need him
you know i i like you've heard me say
towards the end of the year you you
certainly can argue scotty miller is
right there with antonio brown as far as
the talent he has
maybe not quite the route runner but
more of a big play threat with his speed
and things like that
so i think it's the same thing like
they'll bring them back but
they're not going to overpay them by one
dollar it's going to be on their terms i
think that's where those two kind of fit
in or if they do fit in
well and with tyler johnson earning his
stripes
in playoffs yeah and putting himself in
a position where
he can be a guy that tom brady trusts
maybe tom brady
no longer has that burning desire to
have antonio brown there
they want a super bowl together maybe
it's run its course maybe it's time for
a b to move on and
incorporate the lessons he's learned
from tom brady elsewhere
he has kept himself under control
off the field for the most part and he
still has that
civil lawsuit hovering over him for
sexual assault and rape
that isn't going anywhere it's supposed
to go to trial in december
it could be that now is the best time
for the buccaneers to say thank you a.b
you get your super bowl ring you were a
contributor
if you hang around you're going to be
lost in the depth chart
you're better off finding another spot
somewhere else and i agree with you on
for now what happened last year with the
chiefs clyde edward zelaire
with the 30-second pick in the draft
right running backs are available in
every round of the draft
and then the second you know all i gotta
do is look at jacksonville they got
james robinson from illinois state
undrafted no doubt so yeah and you don't
know for sure that you're going to find
a guy who can come in and get it done
that way
but if leonard fournette is expecting to
get
money that is more than just the dribs
and drabs we've seen
the one in two year deals in the range
of two three
four million look at what marlon mack he
hardly got anything to go back to
indianapolis now he's coming off
a torn achilles yeah but but but still i
i agree with you
there's no reason to overpay and there
was something that bruce aryan said
in that clip we played at the top
because they have been focused on
keeping their own guys and it's
difficult to go out and start throwing
money
to strangers to the team until you've
taken care of
your guys but aryans acknowledged at
some point they will
and the cap space they've created will
allow them to
and they're going to be able to dangle
some
significant opportunities to come join
the super bowl parade
and there are plenty of guys still out
there that could help make that team
better
and that to me is what's interesting now
maybe even more interesting
than do they keep antonio brown and
leonard fournette i'm intrigued now by
where they pivot
when they start looking at guys to whom
they can offer
coveted and rare spots on this tampa bay
buccaneer team that is trying to make it
back to back i know
you know well they're getting up you
know getting up against it
right on the salary cap so that i don't
think they're gonna be able to spend
like a ton of ton of money but mike
here's the other thing i'll just say
about what you said you know when you
really look at them
you just go where do they need players
that that's what's amazing you just go
where
where do you need a reagency upgrade i
mean
tight end it's a plethora let's not
forget oj howard
is gonna be back right there's another
weapon he's a
he's i think he's i think i think he's a
fifth year option am i not wrong about
that i
i thought let me check be wrong but
check i could be wrong so
i i stand corrected either way my point
would be
there's not room on the roster a whole
lot other than like
i thought it was a fifth year option
pete's saying it was um but
you know anything else they get is depth
or a specialization guy right like oh
maybe we get
you know this guy to again come in to
cover
tight ends something like that again
just icing on the cake type of stuff
i mean offensive line set up receiver
set up
all right running back you know it's
still good ronald jones and keyshawn von
the kid they dropped out of vanderbilt
he's
you know he's he's a good number two
he's got that possibility in him
so that's what's amazing about the
football team they have built a complete
football team and there already is
pretty decent depth to go along with it
and
that's uh it's just rare it's really
rare like we said a few weeks ago
to see a super bowl team not get ravaged
by anybody or anything
in in this salary cap era you don't see
that very often
i bet they would have loved to have
released oj howard before his fifth year
option
payment of 6 million became fully
guaranteed but it was injury guaranteed
he has that torn achilles
they couldn't do it uh offensive line i
think
is an area where they may want to go
bargain shopping just for
depth purposes just for look at what
happened
to the kansas city chiefs when their top
two guys
weren't available for the super bowl
type purposes
you know they did extend the contract of
donovan smith which is good and it
created some more cap space and
and they do have a very good offensive
line but if you get a guy
injured you need to have someone that
you can trust who can step in
not an undrafted free agent not a sixth
round pick
if you can get one of these veterans who
are available in free agency
and have them as a swing
right guard tackle type of a guy or just
a guy who's available on the bench
right for whatever need there may be at
any of those five spots and he's someone
who's been around the block and knows a
thing or two
that that to me would be the one area
that they
would be smartest to bolster with any
cap space they have left once they've
taken care of all the business they want
to take care of with their current
players agreed there
agreed i mean you know you can't have
enough good offensive lineman we know
how dangerous of a position it is
you know that's one of those guys one of
those spots where two guys could go down
in a hurry because
guys fall on their legs in the piles or
whatever else
and you know you got tom brady at
quarterback protection is
is essential like it's essential it's
more for him than
just about anybody else in football with
his age and his
you know inability to really avoid
danger a whole lot and we saw last year
his worst moments
were all pressure related all of them i
mean you could it's actually comical if
you go back and look at it so
i think you're spot on there and you
know it is it's gonna be finding guys
that
hey got a little experience of they
could play center or
guard or this guy's done guard and
tackle
and it's gonna be that but it but again
it's all just
filler when you really look at it i mean
it's truly amazing
and then you know jason light's been
pretty damn good in the draft too
so they're gonna have that aspect and
i'm sure
you know just from what he's done the
last few years i just look at it and man
it's it's been a lot of home runs
and i i wouldn't be shocked if they got
a few more studs in the draft with
he's got an incredible uh eye for talent
he really does i'm a big fan of jason
likes i
every ever since everything except
robert aguayo
like i've always said that was that was
the only pick i've ever looked at him
and gone
what the hell is he thinking other than
that they've all been awesome
and i continue to believe that larry
fitzgerald
could end up with the tampa bay
buccaneers and think about all the
connections light was in arizona aryans
was in israel
and this is a team that by all
appearances
is going to be in the hunt again and
this is a way for larry fitzgerald
to exit with a super bowl ring i made
the comment recently blaine gabbert
has a super bowl ring dan marino dan
fouts
fran tarkington don't plenty of guys
have super bowl rings
that have had no contribution no reason
no and all due respect but we we know
that's how it goes
right place right time you get a super
bowl ring and you don't if there's a way
that you'll take it larry fitzgerald can
cap his career
right and i don't i don't think anyone
with the cardinals or any
arizona fan is going to be upset they
have aj green
they're moving forward he's been there
forever
if he decides he wants to to sign up
with the bucks
for one year to try to get a super bowl
ring
work with tom brady i i think that that
it makes sense for both sides getting a
guy out there with the man of the year
patch on his
jersey everything that he brings to a
team and and
even though i don't think the buccaneers
need it the same way that others do to
avoid complacency
when you do bring in a veteran who
doesn't have a super bowl win yeah who
desperately would like to get one
that can become new jews almost a
rallying cry
it's it it just it keeps guys
from from getting lackadaisical because
what did we do last year we climbed that
mountain what are we trying to do this
year
we're trying to climb that mountain
again we just climbed that mountain
everybody else trying to climb that you
know it's hard to climb that mountain
we just climbed the damn thing you you
want you don't want guys thinking like
that and if you have a larry fitzgerald
there
who is desperate to climb that mountain
that that can help you again they don't
need it with tom brady but
i think it would help he would just give
him another little kick but i don't
think they could get larry fitzgerald
don't disagree with that at all
there's some i don't care tom brady or
not they're you know juice is needed
and it could become a rallying cry to
your point you know one
he could you know like it antonio brown
but in a different way
kind of raise the level of excitement in
the wide receiver room
and it can become a rallying cry where
you know he oh man he he could start
he'll start talking a little bit like oh
i want to get a ring and
guys are going to hear that and they're
going to rally around we want to get
larry a ring
we want to get larry we'll get the old
timer a ring like florio he's an old
timer
i would think that i would think that if
fitz ended up there that that definitely
would end the a b
marriage that would be the end of this
is the anti-antonio
yes it'd be like the total opposite like
it's total opposite guy altogether but
i think there's some logic to that mike
and maybe maybe you're right maybe
you're on to something maybe that's why
he's sitting out there right now
still contemplating and maybe trying to
let tampa figure out their whole
situation
the circumstantial evidence is
overwhelming
when you think about it fitzgerald
crickets
about his intention yeah you're right
slate march he said nothing about it
cardinals they signed aj green which
tells us he ain't going back to the
cardinals
buccaneers systematically going through
their options
and you just pick a day on the calendar
when's the best day
for us to do this and also it's an
opportunity to take over a news cycle
you wait for things to slow down get in
that lull between free agency and the
draft
you pick that right day to make that
transaction
make it known and they'll be
praised it's it's all anyone will be
talking about if you pick the right day
and if there isn't some unexpected news
elsewhere that swoops in and knocks it
off the
the front page of the sports section
larry fitzgerald going to the tampa bay
buccaneers
would be a huge development and it's
hiding in plain sight looking at us
i think it's going to happen put me down
for minus
250 for larry fitzgerald to the
buccaneers pete don't don't try to put
other ideas he's saying that
i don't understand what he's saying i
understand what he's saying like [ __ ]
you know sorry but but yes i i the the
connections are all there
to to tampa to what you're saying you
know with jason light bruce arians all
of that that makes sense tom brady todd
and tom brady i'm sure he and tom brady
are have golf together
they're i'm sure they're friends i'm
sure i mean i don't know the details but
why wouldn't they be they've both been
around the nfl forever they're the two
elders statesmen they're the two
old-timers of the nfl well yeah there
has to be a relationship there already
well i i
i would think so and larry's the kind of
guy like i've been around larry a few
times i mean
you know he you he makes you feel like
you've known him forever even when you
meet him the first time
he's just a he's a great guy he's a
great human being
so he's going to fit in there but like
to answer pete who says the chiefs
you know one yeah the connections with
tampa two
the other thing pete i would say to the
chiefs thing is he doesn't really
fit what they do offensively he's more
of a fit because he can run
you know the option stuff and do all
that stuff in the slot the chiefs don't
do that that's something you've heard me
say
right i'd like to see them do more of
that to grow their offense there
and then the other thing is is you know
a lot of their other past plays are just
like
run as fast as you can that way run as
fast as you can that way and that's not
larry if it's gerald either so that
would be my answer to that pete not to
like uh
say you're wrong it's a good idea i just
think there's a certainly a better fit
there in
in tampa and i reflect on 2008
2000 what was the year of the hail mary
the game when when the packers tied it
up and the cardinals won in overtime
that one year was that was l8 i think i
was at an 08 or oh nine
that was nine no i'm talking about the
one
oh the one a few years ago yeah anyway
i'm thinking of it in the
the wild card game like 20 14 20 20
25 or 15 somewhere in there yeah yeah
remember how possessed and determined he
was
to get the ball into the end zone in
overtime i mean he's got
when he gets into the playoffs he's got
another level
almost like gronk there's another level
that comes through from larry fitzgerald
and
this team's definitely good enough to
get to the playoffs
right we saw the odds for the buccaneers
winning the super bowl
they have improved dramatically yeah
over the course the past several weeks
i play off larry fitzgerald in 2008
that got him a bronze bust regardless of
whatever else he did in his career after
that
he is so good in the postseason can you
imagine him and brady and gronk and mike
evans and chris godwin and all those
other players and that defense if they
get back to the postseason
i think those odds are going to keep
dropping they're almost even with the
kansas city chiefs right now to win the
super bowl and
i know that the team that just won the
super bowl always has that
shine and that's the most recent thing
that we can remember
and it's been almost 20 years since it's
actually happened
wouldn't that be a great book and for
tom brady though to go back to back
in new england and then back to back 20
years later
with a different team in his first two
years with that team
would be unreal hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports